mencionábamos que el libro 'los versos
satánicos' le valió décadas de amenazas
a rossi por parte de grupos religiosos
cuéntenos sobre esta publicación y por
qué generó tanta polémica
hola santiago en primer lugar
permitirme es decir que es un día
tristísimo para la literatura para todos
los escritores elevamos nuestros votos
para que se recupere de salman rushdie
no tenemos noticias sobre su salud pero
de verdad que esto es una noticia muy
triste para para la literatura
me imagino toda la hora de salman
rushdie es una reivindicación de la
libertad toda la hora en los versos
satánicos buenos a esa obra que fue
condenada más bien fue condenado su
autor pero la obra también fue condenada
a la censura en varios países inclusive
en la propia india también puede pues
está prohibida con recursos muy muy
polémicos porque se prohibieron la
importación del libro en fin en toda la
obra de salman rushdie es eso insisto en
una reivindicación sobre la libertad
está esta obra versos satánicos' en gira
en torno de un malentendido que uno
desde la literatura lo podría calificar
hasta de no carente de alguna de alguna
gracia porque el esfuerzo satánico
precisamente en son unos un un
malentendido desde el propio profeta
mahoma que supone que recibió un mensaje
de dios pero esos versos en particular
se los atribuye a satanás bueno en torno
de este malentendido gira ir a la obra
versos satánicos
no existe absolutamente ningún libro
ningún libro en toda la historia de la
literatura que justifique la muerte de
nadie y los atentados de nadie
absolutamente ninguno por más este pro
casco es que pueda ser considerado por
más profano por más ser ético no no
existe motivo alguno para que un
escritor sea condenado a muerte no
existe no existe es este este atentado
no es el único no contra salman rushdie
ya había subido otros un traductor del
propio rating o asesinado en fin e
insisto no no existe un solo motivo para
que un escritor sea sea asesinado
condenado a muerte
federico cree que se vieron
ensombrecidas quizás otras obras suyas
precisamente por estas repercusiones
bueno claro que
sucede sistemáticamente cuando cuando un
libro cuando un autor es censurado
inmediatamente las demás obras caen en
un cono de sombra precisamente por la
resonancia de éstos y es muy muy
desgraciado a quienes alguna vez hemos
padecido la censura lo sufrimos mucho
porque de verdad que es injusto para una
obra sobre todo para versos satánicos'
que sea considerada desde un pequeño
punto de vista cuando es una obra
muchísimo más abarcativa que habla de
cuestiones esencialmente humanas e
insisto que tienen que ver con la
libertad problema es una obra satírica
una obra de un humor fantástico ese
comienzo de novela que están los
protagonistas cayendo de un avión y
conversando en esa en esa caída es
maravilloso entonces claro es
completamente injusto porque se pierde
la esencia no solamente de ese libro
sino de toda la obra que insisto toda la
obra salman rushdie es una una
reivindicación del ejercicio de la
libertad por parte de la literatura
federico bueno sobre esto mismo le
quiero preguntar hizo hincapié en varios
momentos de esta breve entrevista sobre
la libertad no estamos hablando de un
escritor que como ustedes bien dicho
puso muchísimo énfasis en el valor de la
libertad verdad como se refleja esto en
su literatura en su obra
yo quiero destacar dos dimensiones de
almaraz y por supuesto la literaria es
un lector de un reconocimiento
indiscutible pero pero quiero destacar
también a salman rushdie como como
persona yo tuve la ocasión de conocerlo
en guadalajara la pérdida de mexico es
un es un lector finísimo un gran lector
de borges
que conocía prácticamente de memoria
toda la obra de borges
e insisto si hay un rasgo que prevalece
en toda la obra de salman rushdie es
esta está en este ejercicio de la
libertad que no es fácil no es fácil ver
que esté hablando desde argentina ahora
en este momento precisamente se acaba de
embargar un avión iraní venezolano para
decimos dos atentados aquí en la
argentina por parte del terrorismo
islámico y que nos es muy muy cercana a
este tema
de los atentados en principio y de la
del temor a la expresión en libertad
si alguien salman rushdie
no se puede escribir y de hablar con
absoluta libertad y ese este mientras
esperamos es que hacemos votos para
hacer para que se recupere bueno
reivindicamos este carácter
absolutamente éste es favorable a la
libertad que se expresa en la obra y en
la palabra de salman rushdie